meine version von tadel sieht so aus wie
einig ist tut sie aus wie ein zombie
hallo mein name ist luca bei mir sind 35
grad und ein ventilator hat gerade den
geist aufgegeben dass es nicht wahr ein
ventilator zehn milliarden grad deswegen
habe ich nichts an es tut mir leid falls
jemand sagt ich möchte nicht seine
schultern sehen aber sonst ich sterbe
hier drin mir wurden wieder viele bilder
zugesehen unter dem hashtag x mal auf
twitter unter anderem auch dieser affe
hier den ich mal schön nachmalen soll
und damit fange ich jetzt auch direkt an
das leicht ist es fertig das schwarze
jetzt kommen die einzelheiten das ist
voll krass ich war noch nie so man
wächst danke dass du auch mal die farbe
wechselt hier
es wird ja oft kritisiert jan luca du
gibst dir überhaupt keine mühe
es ist aber tatsächlich einfach so ne
ich kann nicht malen das hat nichts mit
keine mühe geben zu tun ich bin einfach
schlecht aber eventuell kann ich dann
mit diesem bild einigen leuten das
gegenteil beweisen ich versuche nehme
ich jetzt so schön wie möglich diesen
affen zu malen weil ich mag affen
ich bin letztens extra in zoo gefahren
nur um die scheiß affen zu sehen und
dann waren die drinnen weil es zu kalt
draußen war man das sind affen die
gründe
ich finde affen alpakas und
landschildkröten sind die schönsten
tiere auf der matte fucking welt kommt
bin ich an mit irgendwelchen hunde ab
manche hunde sind auch süß aber nicht
mit katzen europa eigentlich mag ich
schon alle tiere mich erinnert der affe
so ein bisschen an den affen von hakuna
matata von der könig der löwen
willst du aber das können wir auch schon
direkt feststellen ob er nämlich genauso
aussieht wie der affe von könig der
löwen denn ich werde jetzt einfach mal
mein bildschirm revieren es ging sehr
schnell
es sind ja auch nicht so viele details
zu beachten aber wir achten jetzt
einfach mal drauf das ist das ursprungs
wird meine lieben freunde jetzt mein
originales bild sehen was ist eigentlich
überhaupt nicht zu erkennen dass das ein
ist das überhaupt ein affe also mainz
sieht aus wie eine mischung aus einer
straßenlaterne und einem straßenköter
das fast es eigentlich ganz gut zusammen
aber freunde das bild wird natürlich
trotzdem abgespeichert ich weiß echt
nicht ob ich euch das auf dem video der
schinken soll oder nicht das ist
eigentlich eine beleidigung an die
komplette kunstszene unter dem
vorletzten video hat sturm werfel runter
geschrieben dass ich ihnen grün malen
soll deswegen habe ich mir hier ein
tolles bild von 12 ausgesucht und male
ihn einfach mal grün an
also letztes das bild mit paola und die
war ja schon krass an der grenze kann
man die überhaupt noch erkennen
allerdings bin ich bei diesem bild mir
sehr sicher dass der geringste
wiedererkennungswert bestehen wird den
ich je bei irgendeinem wild zu verbuchen
hatte ich bin gerade total verwirrt ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung wo was ist
was ich schon gemalt habe wo irgendwie
die nase ist oder irgendwas das wird so
scheiße
ich weiß überhaupt nicht was ich weiß ob
ich dieses bild jetzt gut heißen soll
oder ob ich sagen soll das ist total
scheiße oder whatever
aber es ist erinnert mich sehr stark an
hulk oder shrek da bin ich mir ganz
sicher meinte smith mit seinen 47 jahren
hat natürlich auch schon die ein oder
andere midlife crisis sorgenfalten auf
der stirn vorhanden deswegen bin ich
hier auf jeden fall so ein bisschen
dabei dass ich die schon mal malen werde
und wir als sind denke ich fertig dass
meine lieben freunde ist das
ursprüngliche bild was sich aus den
google bildern geklaut habe und jetzt
mal lieber 12 eine version von dir sein
mir bitte nicht allzu böse doch du
darfst mir böse sein also bei längerem
beobachten mir fällt tatsächlich
überhaupt kein unterschied auch wir
sehen den originalen 12 auf der rechten
seite und den gemalten smith auf der
linken komme jetzt bin ich schon so
durcheinander gekommen weil der so nah
an der realität ich keine ahnung also
sorry smith das hab ich überhaupt nicht
hingekriegt dass du mir leid aber du
wolltest dass ich in grün male und das
habe ich jetzt hier mit getan und das
bild wird natürlich auch wieder
abgespeichert spätestens jetzt wird
jedes fan girl sagen aber ja ihr habt
richtig gesehen ich habe mir gedacht ich
meine bzw wird ist mir unter den hashtag
gepostet und das bild passt eigentlich
auch perfekt also ich mach das mal eben
kurz ein bisschen kleiner damit ich das
gleich schön auf speichern kann aber ich
find's super ich kann daraus echt schade
wenn du das siehst
ich mach dich jetzt schöner wir hatten
richtig blasser haut
also ich weiß nicht ob sie offen auf dem
bild so ist also nicht geht es
eigentlich klar aber auf dem bild sieht
die haut echt einfach weiß aus die haut
ist so blass dass ich nicht mal wirklich
hier sehen kann was ich schon bemalt
habe und was ich noch nicht bemalt habe
weil die haut einfach nahezu weiß ist
das heißt dass wir jetzt erst wenn ich
hier den pulli male das ist total crazy
das witzige ist ja auch einfach ich
hatte meine haare als ich 14 war genauso
wie tadel auf diesen bildern ich denke
nicht dass auf dem bild 14 war und
mittlerweile hat er die haare auch
komplett anders aber als ich 14 war
kannte ich halt youtube noch gar nicht
und hat sich die haare aber genauso weil
ich immer nie zum friseur wollte weil
ich wollte mal sonstiges ketchum
überhaupt nicht glücklich war er schwarz
ist auch eine andere story is eh schon
kommen alter dieses video hat locker
zehn trilliarden disney tadel nicht
schön gemalt
ich hoffe ich habe die ohren nicht mit
haaren voll gemalt oder sind die einfach
von den haaren bedeckt auf diesem bild
ist tut mir leid ich kann nicht mal
kommen wir zum wichtigsten an einem
menschen die zähne
denn wir auch die farbe ist wieder so
hell dass ich nicht sagen kann wo ich
gemalt habe die noch schön die lippen
und die lippen sind jetzt fertig und
jetzt sind wir nämlich auch schon mit
dem kompletten bild fertig das heißt sie
drehen die deckkraft vom oberen mal
wieder komplett auf die option
vorheriges bild süsser kleiner tadel mit
mitbieten augen und ich glaub ich hab
die augen vergessen tatsache freunde ich
habe tatsächlich die augen vergessen der
soll so glaubt knallige augen auf diesem
bild das heißt da kommt einfach mal von
club und sein klub ins andere auge und
dann fangen wir wieder von vorne an also
hier 100 das ist der name prozent meine
version von tadel sieht so aus wie einig
ist tut sie aus wie ein zombie um ein
fucking karte sie aus wie mit gruppen
wie eine oma einfach ist tatsächlich aus
wie eine oma wegen der weißen haut und
ich habe die zahlen strukturen vergessen
was sind zahlen strukturen luca wenn man
ganz genau hinschaut kann man aber ein
tadel erkennen glaube ich so jetzt jeder
mal hier zack hand vors gesicht nicht
durch gucken nicht durch gucken freunde
und jetzt machen wir wieder beim und
luca voll schön mal datamatics gilt die
natürlich auch wieder schön meine
unterschrift hin so dass mir keiner
später sagen kann ja auch luca
das ist überhaupt nicht von dir das ist
viel zu schön für dich total aus scheiße
ich kann es nicht mit dieser
unterschrift von crafter c copyright so
wir haben das bild fertig das wird
abgespeichert und wenn ihr denkt wo das
ist ein schwarzer punkt wenn ihr denkt
wow das ist hammer aus dann könnte mich
ob bei auf dem video days darauf
ansprechen ich denke sogar vergisst die
bilder einfach auf die video technik
keine ahnung also wenn ihr die haben
wollt dann schreibt einfach maligen
kommentare keine ahnung hinzu schreibt
allemal valukas dem avant des pic und
dann schaue ich mal was ich da machen
kann
sonst würde ich sagen das hier war das
letzte der drei gemalten bilder für
heute wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich meine bewertung freuen ich würde
mich über ein abonnement freuen und ich
gehe jetzt in die badeanstalt oder auf
dem mond im weltraum irgendwo wo es kühl
ist es